españa ha despertado hoy tras la primera
noche de toque de queda decretado en
todo el país excepto en las islas
canarias un 'toque de queda' que va
desde las 11 de la noche a las 6 de la
mañana pero que cada comunidad autónoma
tiene potestad de alargar o reducir una
hora por delante y por detrás esta es
una medida que no tiene precedentes
desde que se restableció la democracia
aquí en españa y es quizás de la
consecuencia más llamativa del decreto
de estado de alarma que entró en vigor
ayer en todo el país un decreto que fue
petición de distintas comunidades
autónomas para blindar las medidas que
limitan los derechos fundamentales y las
libertades individuales como es la
libertad de movimientos medidas que
previamente habían sido tumbadas por
distintos tribunales autonómicos y que
ahora quedan a blindadas bajo este marco
constitucional bajo este régimen de
excepción sin embargo el gobierno ya
anunció que el objetivo de momento es
evitar un confinamiento domiciliario
como el que se produjo en la primavera
de este año 2020 y un cierre total de la
economía sin embargo la sorpresa fue que
el gobierno pretende alargar el estado
de alarma hasta
de mayo del año 2021 sin embargo el
decreto actual de momento va hasta el 9
de noviembre y una posible prórroga
tendría que contar con la mayoría del
congreso de los diputados así que a lo
largo de estos días iremos conociendo
los apoyos parlamentarios con el que
quest con el que cuenta esta medida para
saber cuál es el futuro de este decreto
de estado de alarma